in 1648 the waterboard of luck duck
Bhavan dumbs
needs to repair these embankments to
make sure that this bit of a Netherlands
didn't flood for that they needed money
so they sold a bearer bond whoever owned
that bond will get a little bit of money
back from them every year but unlike
modern bottoms they didn't set a time
limit on that perpetual debt can be a
thing in finance it's kind of like
selling stock in a company but normally
perpetual just means until the company
fails but this company didn't fail three
and a half centuries later that original
bond ended up here at Yale University in
New Haven Connecticut USA and it's still
paying interest perpetual barns dates
back to the Middle Ages all bonds were
perpetual bonds and the fact that bonds
actually mature and pay back their
principal is a financial innovation the
floodplains of rivers they don't
coincide with state boundaries or city
boundaries so they had separate
governments that would oversee
deliveries these organizations would
have the power of taxation because we're
ready who is protected by a levy would
pay taxes to 48 but it paid for their
upkeep and it would never go to war so
the combination of being able to tax
people are not going to war which
usually bankrupts governments makes that
these bonds are still paying interesting
today tax collections were fell short of
the budget they needed so the issue this
bond the water board which dates back to
I think 1328 has been merged in larger
and larger organizations they have
recombined these water boards and now
it's called sticky angleman which pays
the interest on the bond these
annotations here are the annual interest
payments that have been taking place
since 1648 as you go to the other side
you see that the whole other side is
also full with little markings which are
the interest payments that have taken
back over the years at some point the
bond was full of a no more space and
they issued this piece of paper here
which is a continued marking of the
interest payments when Yale bought a
bond in 2003 and we collected our
interest payment you see that the last
in
payment had been taking place in 1976 so
there was 27 years of back interest that
was due we left a bond here for 12 years
and then in 2015 we collected to four or
five or six all the way down to 2015
there's actually a picture somewhere of
me in Holland where I hold the bond in
one hand and got interest payments for
four year with my other hand as the
bearer of the bond it's a little
disappointing the bond initially was
four thousand Corollas guilders Corollas
guilders became other guilders I think
they became now euros at some point they
lowered the interest payments a bit so
to make a long story short every year we
get 11 euros and 35 cents interest
payment on this bond you know the value
of this bond obviously is in the fact
that it is its life it's probably just
as exciting for them as it is for us to
be able to present at the bond and have
an opportunity to pay interest now the
Dutch Water Authority could probably
default on the debt if they wanted to it
cost more than the bond is worth to fly
someone over every couple of decades
unless face it Yale would be unlikely to
launch an international lawsuit but for
about 1 euro month the water authority
gets to be part of a weird bit of living
financial history and get a bit of good
publicity out of it too it might not be
a subscription they take out
deliberately but apparently for them
it's worth it I think they have a pretty
good track record they sound like a
triple-a organisation to me and I think
we're going to be good for a while